I'm not sure how I did this,
but it's like a EU Halo. Anyways,
of course I wanna talk about the EU with you
and specifically about the European elections.
Cause if you are from a European Union country,
then you can vote between June 6th and June 9th,
depending on your nationality and your country.
If you have an EU nationality and you live in another country,
you may be able to vote abroad,
but you have to probably sign up for this beforehand.
And if you are an EU national national living in another EU country,
you might be able to choose between
do you want to vote for your home country or your host country?
If you can, then it is very, very,
very important to vote because the EU has a lot of impact on our lives
whether you like it or not.
The EU decides what kind of food we can have,
how we can export and imported,
the products that we use, the currency that we use.
A lot of our laws in you countries,
most of them actually come from Brussels.
The parties should be relatively familiar to you
because it's usually the same parties at the national level.
Not always the smallest party,
but still these parties should be familiar.
It's a very useful website
to check out how you can vote in your country.
This is elections dot Europa dot e U.
They're not sponsoring me,
I'm not sponsoring them, nothing like that.
It's just a useful website.
And I'm gonna upload a podcast episode later.
I'll share it to you about 15,
20 minutes, where I explained European elections in more depth.
So please vote.